the Helmand wouldn't work in their first
series or two so I just might know how
to land just calling plays and stuff
like that you consider all the time out
or you're just like no there's no need
to I mean I you know shadi and I are so
close you know kind understanding what
we want to do and how we want to attack
the defense and you know playing this
game for a while you know so it's it's
good just you know just continue to keep
the pressure on the defense no helmet
communication no problem for Seahawks
quarterback Russell Wilson what would
Jared Goff do if he didn't have the
ability to have Sean McVeigh pulled his
strings on every play oh well yeah I
mean that's they listen I'm not mad at
Sean McVeigh or Jared Goff I don't like
to just aloud but if I if it was allowed
I'd want my coach to be talking to me
too or I was Gordon yeah I mean yeah
there's probably a few moments where I
want to shoot him the middle finger and
tell him to shut up but I get it you
take advantage of the rules so I'm not
mad there but Russell Wilson yeah
within that offense has a good
understanding of what is wanting to be
accomplished he's got years with Pete
Carroll he knows certain situational
football and he's just he's amazing he
really is week after week he just makes
incredible plays and big moments and
just never never lets you down 23 of 33
for 295 two touchdowns no picks nine
rushing attempts 31 yards and a
touchdown he has 14 touchdown passes and
zero interceptions passer rating in
excess of 120 I spoke to him after the
game yesterday and he said look this is
just kind of where you are into year
eight of your career he's he's got week
after week he's never missed a game the
preparation that builds on itself and
he's at a point where he's very
confident about what he sees out there
yeah and he believes that you can't show
him anything he hasn't already seen now
you know that's part of the game they
constantly evolve defenses but you know
he's he's got the skills that he can
make things happen
when you think you've got him hemmed in
right and then once it breaks down I
think that's where he's mastered the
game yeah when it becomes backyard
football and there is no real script at
that point and it's just chaos he sees
away through that chaos unlike most
other quarterbacks can he does it's it's
phenomenal I mean it really is when he
gets outside of the pocket or it's a big
third down he's just one of those guys
where you go if he's gonna find a way to
deliver here whether it's throwing a
strike downfield or extending a play or
running up in the pocket and running
the first down whatever it is you know
he's got a special special skill set he
is unfazed by any situation I mean hey
this is the guy that drove down the
field and you know scored a touchdown
against the New England Patriots in the
closing minutes of a game and you think
they're gonna win the Super Bowl right I
mean he just he's amazingly clutched
that way
he's so determined and you know the
Seahawks you know they're 5 and 1 and I
don't even think they're as good as
they're gonna be yet I think that's
really the big thing we know they're
gonna run the football I think it's
maybe the most talented explosive
receiving corps he's ever had there when
you go lock it met cap Jaron brown and
more that's really an impressive four
they're gonna put you in bind with the
run game who we want to put extra people
in the in the box to stop it oh it's
one-on-one well watch out Russell is
phenomenal that way and then they get to
run read back this week Geron reads one
of the best defensive tackles in
football and a Zico Anza and Jadeveon
Clowney are kind of just getting into
football shape without being there for
training camp and everything and I just
think their defenses their defensive
front is probably just starting to kind
of come to its pinnacle they're gonna
miss well dis Lee yes Russell Wilson
told me that you know he they're very
close and that this is an inspiration in
the weight room he works hard he does
everything he's supposed to do Wilson is
confident he'll be back and better than
ever but for now they're not gonna have
him and that's gonna be an issue but is
we've established Wilson is may be the
MVP frontrunner for now who are your
other candidates well I think you look
at of course Patrick mahomes he's still
in that conversation and I think he's
still gonna put up absurd numbers
especially when they get healthy on the
offensive side of the ball so I don't
look at that as being any different
DeSean Watson's in that conversation I
think at this point absolutely yeah I
mean Christian McCaffrey deserves to be
in the conversation as well I think I
look at those am I missing anybody else
that you know you think's really obvious
there you know I hi I hate to sound like
you and I know the numbers aren't there
but if the Packers end up with the
number one seed how do you not put Aaron
Rodgers in the discussion yeah I hear
you I don't know if the numbers will be
gaudy enough but it's number one yeah
right right right I know I know
and you know again the the stats aren't
going to tell the truth
worried about Aaron Rodgers right now
you know if you went back and we watched
the Cowboys game from last week he
really made some plays that only him and
deshaun Watson and my Holmes and Russell
Wilson could make that got them in some
Jam and got them out of some jams like
you know this one oh hey yeah there's
pressure nobody's open no I'll just
scramble out the right and throw a laser
25 yards down the field no problem you
know that's where he's getting them out
of jams right now they're not
necessarily this play I mean this is
insane up in the pocket off the wrong
leg go don't worry I'll throw it sidearm
up the sideline on point oh here's
another one I'm gonna get cut in half
I'll get it out and throw a laser after
the sidelines Aaron Jones who makes a
great play after but I don't know if the
numbers will be the same but his still
playmaking ability and talent is gonna
get them over the hump on the offensive
side of the ball where it is the true
essence of an MVP about Lamar Jackson
yeah you're Mike I he'd got to be in the
combo right now 50 yards per game
passing right he's middle of the pack
slightly above middle of the pack as a
passer yeah but he's the number eight
rush right now in the entire NFL with
460 yards just behind Marlon Mac and his
eql it's only got 21 then Lamar Jackson
I worried him I worry that he's not
gonna stay healthy but if he does yeah I
know he's in there and they continue to
win football games because they're
winning football games because of Lamar
Jackson's talent I mean you know
especially when you see no Hollywood
Brown in their lineup right now you go
what is there to really be scared about
on that Ravens often so then they have
great size on their offensive line
oh-ho Craig great teams pack it in there
they can stop the inside run but Lamar
Jackson's ability to run on the edge and
then his passing has really been
consistent all year long and we talked
about there's you know not a ton of like
explosiveness they they got good tight
end play and things like that but I'm
really impressed with what I've seen
from large acts
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports